I reject nation on Greg Alba what's your
name Courtney right it's a little little
bit of improv we did there you see kids
you too can yes and at home Courtney
have you ever done it try not to laugh
challenge I never have
she never has can you believe that well
the rules are simple that thing you love
to do so much that's good for your heart
that's good for life you're gonna have
to just bottle that [ __ ] up and bury you
suppress the joy and happiness are
really hard I can do this I could do
this you watch Family Guy yes well we're
gonna do a family catch that's the last
challenge I fire up with that video
really okay my game face now okay here's
how this works
all right we're gonna do a whole thing
if you happen to laugh don't worry I'm
not gonna get mad at you just keep going
along alright don't do this you want
annoys me what people do in trying to
laugh challenges I haven't really seen
other Transpo challenges but when they
do they hear when people are like screw
it I'm just gonna laugh anyway no Yuri
stop alright not smart
you cannot smile so if you happen to
break I totally get it you just reset
everyone over thinks this and maybes cuz
i over explain it
[Music]
mom what is that over there playing
chess with Tricia Takanawa because Chris
get idiot father thinks she's his new
tiger mom is trying to impress her all
right Peter it's time to master the game
of chess
okay it shouldn't be too hard no you
will do it in the traditional Japanese
way on a wacky game show while a
beautiful woman beats your scrotum with
a lead that was the back door
but shortly afterwards I was almost
eaten alive by a good knows we're out
here
just knowing what's safe to eat and
what's not okay
[Music]
Publishing you want to get a book
published don't you Wow yes well you
want to be in black and white black and
whites gotta be in you
[Music]
[Music]
I'm actually glad you're all here
tonight I want to tell you that one of
you will betray me all right
so there I was they've just beaten me
senseless got thorns in my head nailed
me to a piece of wood shoved a sponge
full of vinegar in my mouth
and killed me then they put me in a hole
with a rock in front of it for two whole
days and come Sunday Bank I rest from
the dead so me and Cleveland a Joe it
just wrecked on Southern Comfort right
we know we're gonna puke but Joe says
let's go see Chronicles of Riddick
sector the whole thing when I lost my
glasses
how do we know you're really Jesus can
you perform miracles sure how about this
I love you too Philip hey Jesus can you
do something for me sure Peter what is
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he'll be stuff yeah I like to pretend
it's mine down here what you want always
slapping Museum of Science
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
music music is expressly forbidden
inside prison walls
good how can you be so obtuse what are
you - you'll be in a - two months - the
whole now you'll be in a queue
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
those are tumors for some reason their
jesus bits on here really crack me maybe
cos growing up Catholic pretty devoted
Catholic breathe deeply
I couldn't tell like it's cornea noise
right now or is she like trying to not
laugh I could yeah there's some great
bits here family oh that one that one
started a game that one they're great at
their offensive humor man yeah you did
great thank you thank you
yeah Wow that was very very sincere hey
you did that cuz yeah you're like well I
I couldn't tell what you're doing but
then like Jiri you've like burst out and
snicker a little bit why she was really
trying not to love it very impressive
because you do laughing you got a good
laugh Oh
laughing like really like I was like
this challenge is going to be difficult
I'm ready
Philip I love that line I love laughing
I hate comedy who's that guy Courtney I
want to say thank you for being here
thanks for having me you were a great
try not to laugh companion I think you
do it really good in real life when
we're hanging out so that was the joke
that was the jokes Courtney Shh guys you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell follow Courtney
right on Instagram and Twitter links in
the description box in pink comment
check us on patreon weekly Q&A Stevie
Show reaction watch along this music
video coverage would love to have you
become a patron of Jack today and you
can also get a shirt